Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos hoy en reporteros traemos la
historia de Rafael Moreno un periodista
colombiano asesinado en octubre de 2022
que residía en Monte Líbano una pequeña
localidad rural del departamento de
Córdoba y una de las zonas más
marginadas y violentas del país la
organización Stories cuya misión es
proteger perseguir Y publicar el trabajo
de periodistas amenazados encarcelados o
asesinados creó el proyecto Rafael donde
trabajaron 30 periodistas de distintas
organizaciones entre ellas France 24 rp
el país el espectador y click Moreno
antes de ser silenciado denunció la
corrupción y la delincuencia en su
región desde la malversación de
contratos públicos hasta la extracción
ilegal de recursos una labor que acabó
costándole la vida el papel de los
comunicadores y los medios fue retomar
sus investigaciones y sacar a la luz los
métodos condenatorios de las empresas
que investigaba cientos de documentos y
correos electrónicos que Rafael aún no
había hecho públicos fueron examinados
para esta investigación hoy nos acompaña
Felipe Morales periodista del diario El
espectador de Colombia uno de los
participantes del proyecto les saludo
Felipe y quería preguntarle cuánto
tiempo trabajaron con forbidden en este
proyecto y cuál fue el resultado que
pudieron corroborar Y si pudieron
corroborar las denuncias que había hecho
Rafael
Hola herminia Muchas gracias por por
este espacio
en efecto estuvimos trabajando desde
octubre de 2022 cuando Asesinan a Rafael
Moreno
una una un contexto muy importante de su
homicidio es que él ya sabía había
recibido muchas amenazas y sabía que
estaba en un en un riesgo tremendo y él
había entrado en un contacto previo
conformidad Stories en octubre de 2022
él habla con con el con el equipo
francés les entrega una serie de
documentos y él tenía planeado viajar a
Bogotá
a entregarles otra serie de documentos y
a comenzar a trabajar con ellos pero ahí
es que lo asesina entonces nuestro
trabajo parte de una serie de documentos
que que él alcanzó a entregar la Ford
Stories así como de otros Pues que
encontramos en el camino y desde luego
pudimos corroborar las denuncias que él
hacía tanto frente a la gran minería en
Córdoba como frente a hechos de
corrupción en ese departamento
sí Felipe gracias Ya volvemos con usted
aquí la historia
[Música]
Bueno te cuento pues mi trabajo
está dirigido más que todo al tema de
factores generadores de violencia el
tema de corrupción
trabajamos con el tema de medio ambiente
nueve días después de esta llamada
Rafael Moreno fue asesinado en el local
de comidas rápidas que acababa de abrir
para llegar a fin de mes
deja cuatro hijos y una viuda Kiara
la familia teme que el crimen que te
impune como suele pasar en Colombia
[Música]
lógicamente cuando tú tocas esos temas
si tú denuncias esos temas pues
lógicamente los grupos al margen de la
ley se van a sentir ofendidos
y ha recibido amenazadas De qué grupo
armado precisamente
cuando estuvieron los distintos
paramilitares me amenazaron
paramilitares ahora que está el cabo
clan del Golfo me ha amenazado
[Risas]
[Música]
me da miedo que pase lo que ha pasado
siempre
que el poder que la plata
que compren tanto
y uno con tanto dolor con tanta
impotencia
para sus amigos era el periodista del
pueblo su página de Facebook las voces
de Córdoba tenía más de 50.000
seguidores
Hola Qué tal amigos
de voces de Córdoba Bienvenidos a una
transmisión más con su amigo y servidor
Rafael Moreno nos encontramos en este
momento en la entrada principal de la
mina de sator
yo Rafael Moreno critico las empresas
basado en investigaciones en trabajo de
campo y en entrevistas a las comunidades
este fue el cráter que dejó el atentado
realizado a la policía Rafael Moreno se
presentaba como un defensor de los
recursos de su región desde la
corrupción de los clanes políticos hasta
la contaminación y los abusos de las
empresas mineras denunciaba casos en los
que siempre pierden nos más Humildes
es una maldición vivir en un territorio
tan rico como Córdoba
es una maldición tener tanta vegetación
tener tanta agua y aparte de eso tener
carbón y tener oro y tener cobre
para el ser humano el ser humano de a
pie del común es una maldición
[Música]
Esos carros son de la empresa una
multinacional con base en los Estados
Unidos ha obtenido la concesión minera
de gran parte de la región Hola la
empresa planea excavar aquí una mina de
cobre a cielo abierto como sus
operaciones están dentro de nuestra de
nuestra población pues ellos pasan todos
los días
trescientas familias viven de la
extracción artesanal de oro en la mina
en Alacrán llevan ahí medio siglo pero
pronto serán expulsadas del territorio
Rafael Moreno conocía bien esta
comunidad de Pequeños mineros donde
trabajó con su padre durante un tiempo
vertical sobre cuerdas en el ejército
[Aplausos]
a menudo los visitaba y daba a conocer
su lucha contra la empresa minera
Rafael era de aquí él se crió aquí en
nuestro territorio
de un momento a otro empezamos a verlo
transmitiendo información desde su
teléfono y todo mundo sabe que aquí en
Colombia hablar de algo te hace
te expone el atacó tantos frentes
denunció tantas cosas que uno no sabe
hoy en día quien mató a Rafa
el Por qué está claro porque era una
persona que hacía visible lo invisible
allá en la Vereda Del Alacrán Donde
antes se respiraba Paz
hoy se respira zozobra y miedo
allá ya se acabó la tranquilidad al
igual que Colombia la región del sur de
Córdoba padece múltiples conflictos
ese día los manifestantes protestan
contra la destrucción por parte del
gobierno de áreas ilegales ubicadas en
los ríos para explotar el oro
se cree que pertenecen al clan del Golfo
el cartel todopoderoso en la región
las autoridades acusan al grupo armado
de organizar las protestas de los
mineros dirigidas por estos encapuchados
estamos aquí transmitiendo en vivo para
organismos noticias en estos momentos
acaban de atravesar una mula para
impedir el acceso de tanto de
motocicletas como de vehículos
organismos cuadrado trabajaba
frecuentemente con Rafael Moreno al
igual que él difunde las noticias
locales en las redes sociales
para ayudar esta transmisión pueden
colaborar ahí con la causa
Bueno vamos a cortar la transmisión
Porque allá veo que vienen encapuchados
con palo Entonces es mejor evitar en
temas de seguridad el periodista vive
con estrictas medidas de protección tras
el asesinato de Rafael Moreno el estado
colombiano le proporcionó dos
guardaespaldas y un vehículo blindado
los dos investigaban juntos casos de
corrupción
eso es que van a pavimentar por ejemplo
esta vía y meten la hacen por 5 mil
millones de pesos
hay veces que la hacen no de la calidad
buena y meten dos mil millones y se
roban tres mil hay veces que no la hacen
y toman foto en otro sector y la hacen
pasar como si estuviera hecha así
funciona eso entre otros temas Rafael
Moreno se interesaba de cerca a la
construcción del estadio municipal de
Puerto libertador la obra iniciada por
la alcaldía en 2018 está todavía sin
terminar Lore bautizó el estadio de la
eternidad estamos nuevamente visitando
el estadio la eternidad y hemos
encontrado una cantidad de cosas nuevas
pero no buenas horribles vean me tocó
venirme para la eternidad en botica de
caucho repito queridos amigos es un
proyecto que lleva aproximadamente 7 mil
millones de pesos invertidos
en Colombia los contratos
gubernamentales deben ser publicados en
internet el periodista examinaba los de
su región y los comparaba con la
realidad
queridos ciudadanos
que un hospital como el hospital de
montelibano se gasta 136 millones de
pesos en cafeterías en la historia que
yo quiero contarles de un gran muchacho
que nació en esta región su nombre Rafa
con cariño le decían el defensor de los
recursos de la región
en Puerto libertador cuentan que las
calles aledañas a la casa de la familia
nunca fueron pavimentadas en represalia
a sus denuncias yo todavía conservo un
par de zapatos de Rafa para el día que
la arregle porque me los voy a colocar
en honor a él y la voy a caminar con sus
zapatos
[Música]
La amenaza eran constantes incluso hasta
conmigo este una vez le llegó un mensaje
al celular diciendo que ya sabían A qué
me dedicaba yo que donde estudiaba el
niño él estaba investigando en todo
Córdoba y se metía Pues con diferentes
Por decirlo así mafias políticas del
departamento entonces por eso nos daba
miedo mucho miedo Rafael Moreno No
revelaba a sus familiares los detalles
de sus investigaciones para evitar
exponerlos
cuando él inició Pues con todo esto
obviamente aquí nadie estuvo de acuerdo
absolutamente nadie vida le hicieron
mucho daño demasiado al punto de que lo
ponían en contra grupo a grupos ilegales
Y cuántas veces no le tocó a mi hermano
ir allá frente a grupos ilegales a
defenderse porque ya habían dado la
orden de mandar de que lo sacaran del
camino
Rafael no podía salir en discotecas
porque salían los los más chachitos de a
querer agredirlo a querer golpearlo y
muchas veces lo golpearon
[Música]
este panfleto me lo mandaron hace poco
dije intimidandome diciéndome que
parcero usted se cree el putica porque
habla en público y por eso cree que es
Intocable y en el papel que le meten a
la vaina me mandan esto
en el papel me mandan esto
[Música]
en Colombia corrupción y violencia van a
menudo de la mano
en Córdoba el asesinato de Rafael Moreno
ha silenciado a los pocos denunciantes
ya son las 11 de la mañana 15 minutos 11
15 minutos aquí estamos compartiendo
buena música a través de la piragua
organismos cuadrado por su parte ha
dejado de tratar temas delicados
no sabemos si fue el tema político
porque pues nosotros tacábamos tanto
política como empresas
una fuente le informa del avance de la
investigación
la organización es el nombre bajo el
cual se conoce al clan del Golfo en la
región como que cogiera alguna persona y
esa persona cantó O sea no fue la
organización en sí sino como como que
fue con un pago por aparte Pero alguien
de la organización
alguien
pago tremendo
el clan del Golfo que se hace Llamar
autodefensas gaitanistas de Colombia a
jesé es el principal cartel de la droga
en Colombia cuenta con el ejército de
mercenarios y se lleva su parte de todas
las actividades lucrativas desde las
minas hasta los contratos públicos
Córdoba es uno de sus bastiones nada se
mueve aquí sin su consentimiento
este video de una cámara de vigilancia
grabó el sicario El hombre entra al
local donde el periodista está sentado
en montelíbano dispare varias veces y
huye
[Música]
y si me van a matar mátenme
pero les digo de frente no me van a
silenciar
la voz de Rafael Moreno se ha apagado
pero sus denuncias siguen vidas
cuando se me olvida el tono En dónde
estaba Y de donde
me compongo me compongo
y lo resolvió
[Música]
estamos de vuelta con Felipe Morales
para hablar un poco más el proyecto
Rafael de Stories Felipe Cuáles fueron
los principales retos de esta
investigación para los periodistas que
participaron en ella
Bueno un reto muy especial es que
Córdoba es una ciudad es una región en
la que el conflicto armado continúa
presente entonces Muchas de las fuentes
con las que hablamos no estaban
dispuestas a hablar on the record por
ejemplo es muy difícil acceder a
documentación
pública que que permita digamos
conocer realmente Qué es lo que está
sucediendo por ejemplo con los efectos
de la minería en esta región Y a dónde
van los recursos de la minería en esta
región
varios periodistas del consorcio
estuvieron en terreno y entre ellos pues
el equipo de France 24 y Pues digamos
una un reto muy grande si fue
que a pesar de que encontramos mucha
información que corroboraba las
denuncias de Rafael no había
una manera
a quien lo dijera en como con una voz
propia el no había una fuente que
quisiera darnos la cara si se quiere de
esa manera porque persiste mucho miedo y
pues eso es un efecto directo del del
asesinato de un periodista Gracias
Felipe Moreno por acompañarnos hoy hasta
aquí reporteros de la semana recuerde
que para sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima